i love you kristen bell everybody
i love you too hi oh my goodness it's so
nice to see you it's nice to see you too
how are you you know thriving and
surviving and i just spit
and hugging and spitting and chewing
and just anything i saw a mom friend the
other day and she
hugged me on a street corner and i
wanted to scream what are you doing
and you know just living in that really
bizarre weird surreal
sci-fi movie world yeah cause we need
touch right but we literally have been
told by mother earth
not to touch right now yes
yes i first of all
i remember you did a lazy boy commercial
uh a couple years ago and you were
decorating
a room with this woman and you were like
wait actually
let me keep it real and do it the way it
normally is
and then all of a sudden these little
crayola drawings were on the wall
and the furniture was a little must and
the pillows were everywhere and there
was
you know toys on the you know coffee
table
and i remember because i love branding
and one of the things
that i am a very repressed ad man
i love advertising and i think it is so
powerful and subliminal and it it's
yours it's a storytelling art
it's your storytelling i think when you
speak to
reality you connect people and i don't
ever want to
um appear to people like i'm
i mean i try very hard and i'll let you
see that but i don't want to be trying
too hard you know i don't want to be
afraid to be
me i guess which is the person whose
living room is a muck because
my children are feral you know i do know
absolutely and then i like real talk
you're juggling so many things i mean
i'm like is it a veronica mars reboot is
it the good place
wait is it frozen wait okay oh my gosh
and then i was just reading you have the
woman
in the house with netflix queen pins
you're doing
the uh something on the moon uh with
jonathan the good thing
that i think i the the the sort of weird
balance i strike even though i hate that
word because we're always asked about
balance and i'm like to me that's a
four-letter word it's never gonna happen
just be present where you are
that when i'm working i'm like hustling
and i love it and when i'm lazy
i'mma be lazy do you know what i mean
like
i will i there's definitely been a week
over maybe that i've not gotten out of
my pajamas maybe even the same ones like
i'm not ashamed like when i'm lazy i
will go hard
and i respect that about myself i so
agree
about that word balance she is an
elusive bee
that i feel like i'm in like a cat fight
with i'm like pulling her hair
and we're biting each other and hissing
and spitting
and i want to just tie her up and be
like oh god you
one day i'm gonna find you
i'm gonna find your address balance but
it's
i just feel like i fought her for a very
long time that balance
i would go to work and i would think
about my kids all day i would be looking
at
pictures of them on my phone i'd be
talking about them i'd rush to get home
then i'd be
at home and i'd be stressed about work
because i didn't sort of get
the things done that i needed to get
done and i have a good therapist
who talks very uh
curtly to me and he's like you're a
human doing not a human being
you know if you want to change change
and i'm like who is this challenger i'm
speaking to
because he's just very much like i'll
sit here and listen to all your thoughts
about everything or
we can try to make progress you just you
let me know and that to me is like
ignites a challenge of like okay no i
want progress you think i don't want
progress
i want progress i want to evolve um i'm
so competitive
but also i think i just hit a point
where i wasn't as
happy as i wanted to be i too
i love therapy so much and i think if
you go to a gym
and you don't judge that why would you
judge the gym for your mind
and i need both i need both if i don't
exercise i become
a very irritable and uh uh
therapy for the same reason and also cbd
i've become very i i it has helped my
life so much
and that's what i've been doing most of
the year is creating this cbd product
that i really
wanted in my life that i couldn't find
and it's called happy dance oh you have
it yeah
oh yeah it's called happy and we um i
also like yeah i've got it right here
too
we have three products this is just uh
coconut oil
and cbd then we have a lotion which is
like i think the best smell in the world
and a bath bomb
and the reason we only have three is
because i also didn't want to create
a product i felt it was inauthentic to
create something
that like busy moms or anyone would have
to just like apply into their routine
that was
extra so i was like no we just need the
products people already use
infuse them with very high quality cbd
make them clean
vegan cruelty free blah blah blah and
i'm really happy with it and i've been
i've just been this is my new baby this
year and i've been so
um proud of it um i'm such a fan
of like just you and what you put out
into the world you keep it real
you keep it funny you keep it charming
there's heart there's humor and
i don't know like what i love more than
funny women honestly i wasn't planning
on showing you this but you said keep it
real now i
and again i'm competitive so now i'm
like how real are we gonna get
i got dressed up for you right because
i'm on television this is now television
but i didn't do i didn't do as much as i
could have
because yes
yes i love it i
love it
[Music]
you